fun to be here and so I want to talk a
little bit about
ecology wearable computing and augmented
reality and humanistic intelligence is
the main framework h-i humanistic
intelligence and surveillance systems so
first I just want to talk briefly
mention some of the ventures that have
come out of this philosophy or way of
thinking meta augmented reality
eyeglasses we raised 73 million and the
our chief technology officer so I'm the
chief scientist and one of the
cofounders and I have here another
co-founder with me Raymond you want to
stand up and big applause for Raymond hi
everybody
well I've been working with Steve for
the last 10 years it was a really
interesting venture you see first day I
saw him wearing this into the class and
tell me he can see Wi-Fi I'm not gonna
ruin his talk but definitely he can see
beyond a lot of things we can see today
and I'm very glad to be here and if you
interesting meta come say hi to me today
and we hire if we're looking for very
very smart people and creative people
and then another company that we
co-founded that I was involved with
myself and some of my students and so on
we found it interacts on brainwave
sensing company and raised 17 million
this is our product here I'll just have
that for a second and pass this around
so we sell this in best buy stores
across North America now and and indigo
and so on and this is a transparent
version so you can see inside the ones
that we sell are you know different
colors but usually not transparent but
anyway I'll pass this around so
everybody can see it's got five
electoral points on the front that
contact and then you can plug additional
electrodes into the back for various
areas and it doesn't require if many of
you have seen pictures of me where I
shaved off my hair and bonded a skullcap
permanently to my head with implanted
electrodes but you don't really need
that this will work with a big fuzzy
hairstyle and you don't need in the
electrode gel it just slips on
comfortably and easily and quickly the
other another company visionary tech
we're doing HDR vision and splash tones
we make underwater pipe organs under
musical instruments sort of early
example of a natural user interface and
loose all HDR welding to see Welding
vision all of these companies are
founded from one key principle
humanistic intelligence instead of AI we
have a chai and this is from a paper
that Ray Kurzweil the chief engineer of
Google Marvin Minsky the father of AI
and myself the three of us wrote in 2013
that humanistic intelligence arises by
having the human being in the feedback
loop of the computational process in
which the human computer in extra could
be intertwined and this creates an
intelligence that matches our own
biological brain something more powerful
emerging from this namely a synergy
between human and computer that makes
this sort of super intelligent cyborg
being so it's a fundamental concept
that's based on if we look at the six
signal flow paths between human and
machine think the human I've denoted as
a circle because people are kind of
round and the computer have denoted as a
square because computers are kind of
angular but without loss of generality
here I mean typically computers are
built into clothing so they're also
round and squishy but anyway you've got
the human in the machine and the humans
have senses and effectors and the
machines have scent sores and actuators
and so you might say that there are a
total of four signal flow paths humans
and computers have their inputs and
outputs but I specifically in a chai
theory as we segregate those portions of
the computer's output that are going
into the human and those portions of the
human that are going into the computer
because some of those senses that we
have sense the environment around us and
a portion of that sensory capacities
devoted to sensing the computer so I
specifically segregated those elements
and in particular when we're being
watched
that's called surveillance that's a
French word what does that mean in
English does anybody know English French
here and how to translate it into
English survey surveillance Kiska 70 Ron
Anglais
yeah yeah it's it's a French origin word
but give me like a really nice English
word that sort of yes overlooking or a
really good English word is oversight
over watching or oversight and so
surveillance is over watching and so one
we're being watched over as suspects or
whatever are simply the machines
watching us and so that's surveillance
and in control theory we have this
notion of controllability and
observability need both of them the
contr part two this is su violence
that's a word that I made up severed ear
on ugly under sight and so we have here
these six flow paths and you need all
six of them in order to have a
successful implementation of each eye if
one of them is missing or impaired then
that's a problem now where the problem
mostly arises in is in valence if you
take the word surveillance and take away
the first three letters it just means
sight or watching valence and in
particular just to make a point of this
I made a piece an art installation that
violates the principle of humanistic
intelligence because it's so commonly
done in industry now in fact I grew up
when I could understand things and they
were easy to use and everything was
immediate my computer booted in a
fraction of a second and everything was
instant and then we sort of entered the
dark ages of computing when things
became bad and I think that to
facilitate that to show that I made a
digital light switch push once to turn
it on and push once to turn it off with
a random three to five second delay but
sometimes up to ten or fifteen seconds
even here as a delay was kind of random
and so then with a 90% batting average
so that about 10 percent of the time I'd
ignore the press and so people had come
into my office they pushed the light
switch and nothing would happen and they
would push it again and then I could say
you idiot you just turned the light on
and off again you have to push it and
then wait and they would ask me how long
and I'd say well you know maybe three to
five seconds but sometimes you have to
wait a little longer
and so this is what I was thinking of
machines of malice the digital light
switch being digital now my daughter my
six-year-old daughter made this
understandable because everybody was
saying what does surveillance mean what
does sousveillance mean so I said what's
there to not understand about that and
in fact we created you know hold this is
a necklace I made back in 1998 and I
made it to look like a surveillance
camera and then it captures everything
with a fisheye lens and it's got sensors
in it that connect as it senses all
kinds of physiological and environmental
qualities and then Microsoft kind of
grabbed onto this idea a few years later
and then mimoto actually made it into a
successful product and we can think of
these as scale here you know we can
think of this in terms of scale at the
origin I've got bits atoms and genes and
further out bits as computer science as
we go further from the origin atoms as
geography and physical sciences and
genes beams memes and the social
sciences and so we've got these three
axes alpha cuz at atom is a Greek word
and bits is beta and genes is gamma and
so these three axes represent the
physical and and social political and
compute computational scale of things so
a smart city city comes the word urban
you know as Greek concept of city and
then we've got province country or state
country earth universe and so on and
coming in we've got neighborhood street
building closed body organs inside the
body cellular biology and we have what's
inside and the green stuff is the
environment that's what surrounds us and
I've colored in flesh tones our own body
which is not the environment that's us I
call it the environment and this whole
scale I'll call it the vironment just
take the first two letters off the word
environment so the vironment is the
environment and the environment in other
words the physical scale
we're looking at here and then we've got
the social political scale which is
surveillance versus sousveillance
sousveillance is the small individual
couple family team you know community
corporation nation world government and
even the law of outer space so you can
because he can get pretty big now when
you talk about space law and so we got
sousveillance as the small things and
surveillance is the big things roughly
speaking you know these are all up for
debate but you know the idea is that
we've got the vironment we have valence
and we've got virtuality vironment
valence and virtuality that can occur up
multiple scales and so this is kind of
the philosophical framework and if I had
to summarize one sort of aphorism that
IO proposed to make this understandable
by the layperson h.i is that feedback
delayed as feedback denied when I try to
turn off my TV to tell the kids to go to
bed I used to fix TVs in my childhood I
was the guy that everybody came to with
their TV when it wouldn't be working and
I used to in my early childhood I fixed
televisions and learned a lot about
televisions and turned them into
oscilloscopes and did all kinds of fun
stuff now I can't even figure out how to
turn off the TV because when I push the
button nothing happens so I figure I
haven't pushed it hard enough so I hit
it a little harder and harder and harder
and harder until you see that's the
problem is sometimes it's 15 seconds but
anyway and then I push it maybe wait an
hour and it's still not off so finally I
unplug it and so I thought well it
doesn't give you instant feedback it
doesn't tell you right away so I'd love
to be the CEO of a TV company and just
have a big sledgehammer and they bring
me TVs and I can say okay yes or no I
got to hit it harder and harder and
harder and then eventually somebody will
bring me a TV that immediately
acknowledges the fact that I've pressed
it so these machines know everything
about us but reveal nothing about itself
the TV has a camera in there it's
watching my facial expression knows
everything about me and then yet it's
not even telling me whether or not I've
pushed its on/off switch
so I have this idea of software free
computing and software as a general
pejorative term for anything including
things in the real physical world that
are unreliable and we say that's so
software and so here's a little art
piece I made licensed to sit San
Francisco Art Institute 2001 23 spikes
that retract when you download a seating
license and then I had like six tables
around a six chairs around a table and
you could download a two-seat floating
license and so you could sit at any two
positions and then that way you only pay
for the seating that you actually use
and so this is kind of looks at what
happens if the real world emulates
software here it is here and I don't
know if the sound
so that's kind of my impression of
software and so this was kind of a
vision you know this they asked me for
an exhibit on wearable computing San
Francisco art and student this is what I
gave them you know because I wanted to
say okay what is the future of wearable
computing does it mean that remembering
is we you know seeing is remembering and
remembering is recording and recording
is theft and opens up all those
questions another line of work out is
called direct user interfaces 1998
direct manipulation direct particular
you know manipulation refers to hand
actuation and particulate is foot
actuation and I'll make up a new word
corpus relation don't want to sound too
much like copulation so maybe you have
to kind of be careful with what
declension of the Latin word to use
because Manus means hand and Latin and
so on and so the idea is you have this
this within a feedback loop direct
manipulation or direct interaction shall
we say within a feedback loop with
proper balance between feed-forward
surveillance and feedback sousveillance
and then the other framing I coined the
term natural user interface in 2001
looking at natural nature based natural
philosophy ie physics natural elements
like earth water air fire which are
solid liquid gas plasma and natural use
as in engaging in the real world in a
natural way and that's innate so I
created this reality window manager
where windows are superposed on actual
objects you can reach over and see a
window superposed on something and touch
that window and grab on to it and use
physical space as an interactional
framework that's what I meant and then
Microsoft used this term a little bit
later to mean something different than
what I had originally intended but other
examples are the hydraulic own the mind
mesh look and think instead of point and
click and the eye tab
and so then I wrote this paper being on
digital with digital media and so being
digital means being quantized in both
the domain and range presence of
quantization error quantization noise
the digital era is the first era that's
named after that which we don't want
ie quantization noise how about if we
called the Iron Age the rust age or if
we call the radio age the hiss age or
the static age why are we talking about
the quantization the greedy noisiness of
the air instead of what it actually does
so I kind of put forth this philosophy
being on digital and one of my
inventions HDR high dynamic range
imaging I've put that forward as an
example of being on digital of using of
capturing the floating point underlying
variation that's continuous and getting
rid of the quantization or the
limitations that are typically digital
typically of digital imaging with
compare metric equations so I talked
about being continuous and about fluid
user interfaces I draw the foam
immersive multimedia those who have
brought their bathing suits are welcome
to come to the fountain after class
after the lecture and we can try this
immersive multimedia this is a little
robot that we built which allows you to
interact and touch and grasp on to and
hold waves and so this is like a true
three-dimensional television display
that's truly physically in the
environment with a spinning wheel there
of light and this is the concept another
one of my inventions the chirp let
transform is a mathematical structure
that we've Illustrated here for teaching
purposes this is a microphone and here
we're sensing its capacity to sense the
robot here is is sensing the capacity
since here's a little wearable
wristwatch there's a microphone hidden
inside that little stuffy there and what
we're seeing here is valence waves in
the valence wave the inner product of
the wave with its complex conjugate is
the probability of being detected by the
listening device so we can reach into
quantum theory a little bit and have
some fun
now I've got here this is kind of my
smartphone which of course I've modified
to make it do what I wanted to do in the
frequency pants that I like to operate
it but there's a waveform coming from it
and if I'm close to it you can see that
the signal strong in a front further
away you can see that it's weak we just
actually that's big that's good that's
good you can see it now so here we are
close couldn't see it fairly strong and
as I come further away it's weaker the
waves weaker and what happens if does
anybody so this is early approached
augmented reality they came up with a
1974 for reality but without special
glasses and now if I put my hand over
this see how strong it is Mel with my
hands walking up how much that's getting
through my hand so now that tells me
that if I fold like this maybe put legs
back on if I put my palm up this I don't
hello I can't hear you
well what's happening is you're blocking
the radio waves and the phone has to
crank up full blast
tell us your brain wave and that smart
people hold your phone like this oh
that's much better
and now what happens is that the phone
is just
very gentle because it's not having to
blast itself out of your head and waste
all the battery power of keeping up your
brain instead of using a little bit of
added power to actually transmit easily
so that's an example and this is valence
waves um another example plug another
example is hydraulic own underwater pipe
organ and this is one that we built for
the Interior Science Center I don't know
if this one will actually work we just
we haven't even tested it since we got
off the plane right yeah yeah you want
to start it and there might be a little
initial is it going to play there it is
yes oh well well well
we'll bring it outside but it you got
the idea anyway that that that you can
play and understand with with using
water as a medium of interaction and of
course that gave us a discovery of
actual integral kinematics because we
realized that pianos respond to velocity
pipe organs respond to how far down you
press the keys and hydraulic owns
respond to the area under the time
distance curve which is a total new
concept the area under the time distance
curve and here we are area under the
time distance curve this is a ball valve
connected to a set of rings does
everybody know what a ball valve is you
know when it's across no water comes out
and when you turn it a little it opens
water so if you push the if the bar
tilts one inch at the end for ten
seconds it lets about the same amount of
water through as if it tilts 10 inches
for one second in fact the amount of
water that comes out of that valve is
equal to the area under the time
distance curve and that's a new concept
hydraulic own gave birth to a new
concept distance you take the derivative
you get velocity takes a derivative you
get acceleration what comes after that
derivative of acceleration jerk
excellent and again yes nap urge outs
and then crackle and then I call it
poppycock because by the time we take
that much derivatives it's all almost
all noise snap crackle and pop aqaq
remember that and and and so now we have
a basic framework for a new kind of
kinam kinesiology kinematics so
kinematics is normally distance in its
derivatives
but now kinematics is distance and its
derivatives and integrals and so that
give rise to this new kind of fitness
because now I can measure the absent so
you try and do this thing on the Rings
and it sprays water on your head and do
pull-ups on this bar and if it tilts a
little bit tilts more it sprays more
water and then in
of water we put a little app that just
integrates and gives you a number based
on how much abs meant there isn't you
try and do your pull-ups with me to my
maps Minh and then we put on the Metta
glasses and put a racing game where
you're driving a race car down the track
and you got to do pull-ups and steer
while you're doing the pull-ups and this
thing is the steering mechanism so
that's an integral kinesiology or
integral kinematics so it's just another
invention that's another start up
waiting to happen
and I've got all these startups waiting
to happen by the way and I'm open to
collaboration on all of these so if
there's anybody here isn't interested in
kind of working on these things I've got
this little app here running and it
measures the the tilt and maybe you can
hold the mic here
you can start it yourself six five four
three two one zero
so that's 10 good push-ups of the
announcement of 14 so if anyone wants to
try to beat that they'll be fun we can
go come up feel free to give it a try
anyone want to try it
so now we'll start so we'll stop and
then start off you strip get into
push-up position and let it count down
eight yeah get your hands on the floor
okay ready
and wait till it counts down to one game
on right down to the board if you can
that's not bad right down to the board
that's good 75 that's not bad go first
try and as you continue to practice you
can get the abdomen down lower and lower
and so on and I've also got these rings
here and we can take that out and I've
got some rope and hang it from a tree
and after the session we can do the
Rings game which is the same thing and
that on the Left there's a so we just
hang the Rings from the fire escape
stairs or so on do a little bit of
exercise between computing sessions and
so the the alternator there it's an
automobile alternator that's both a
sensor and generator and it throws some
curves at you and you feel the bumps in
the road so you're driving this virtual
reality game and you got a steer right
or steer left and you feel the bumps in
the road coming you got to basically
hold your position in correct error and
that's kind of the fundamental ID here's
another variation of it wrestling with a
robot water robot and so you got a dead
head that jet and there's a fountain
here at Stanford that actually has a
pretty strong jet to deadhead but it can
be dead headed with a single hand so you
can deadhead it with one hand this robot
tries to do evasive maneuvers while
you're trying to deadhead it and
obviously if you come into the jet at
the base you can't get the strength to
deadhead it but if you come from further
back as you come up on it you can and
then it's trying to evade you as this
gets the idea of water over Internet
Protocol so here's two robots that
interact at different places and you can
have a water fight with somebody in
another country for example so we call
that wo IP water over Internet Protocol
and this is an example of immersive
multimedia I define immersive multimedia
roughly or approximately as a multimedia
experience that sort of more or less
requires you to bring a bathing suit and
tell it's an example of something that I
for which I coined the term natural user
interface and the idea is natural
interfaces metaphor free computing
reality user interfaces and the
hydraulic own is an example of that my
kindergarten teacher said there's three
kinds of instruments strings percussion
and wind and I said strings are
one-dimensional solids matter percussion
is two-dimensional membrane or
three-dimensional bulk solid and wind as
gas so we've got 1d solid
multi-dimensional solids and gas so I
said you know like the three states of
matter solid solid and gas strings
percussion and wind and so I said well
something's missing there and how about
I invent a new kind of instrument and
then she said don't be crazy and of
course I asked some physicists and
engineers and they said well you know
water is not compressible you can't make
it into an instrument I said well if
water is not compressible then the speed
of sound and water needs to be exactly
equal to infinity which it isn't
so water is compressible to some degree
but just not on the x on the scale that
we normally have these bulbs here hold
about 3000 pounds per square inch
pressure and the necks are about 750 psi
and we have the water hammer hydraulic
own and this is just a little fun at the
beach here
and if that wasn't an if that experience
wasn't immersive enough
so this is the how we spend our Canadian
winters was -20 was the actual
temperature with a windchill of minus 40
degrees and this was we were the
headline act for the Prime Minister and
the governor-general at the North
America's largest Winter Festival so
this was a lot of fun and
so this is a polyphonic embouchure is
the concept underlying here the
instrument has multiple mouths oh
there's a there's a mechanism here
whereby the sound comes from vibrations
in liquid alone and I'll pass this
around this is due to the effects of
modern printing technology and Max here
stand up give her max our big round of
applause here he's he's a resident
mechanical engineering genius so if
anybody here knows about navier-stokes
equations boundary value problems
through all numbers on bluff bodies you
know join our team past there this isn't
a start-up we're working and we sell
these two water parks all over the world
we've got one at Legoland in Carlsbad
California we've got them some of the
biggest makers of water parks and so on
licensing this technology and we put
them in cultural centers and civic
centers around the world as sculpture
and interaction design and here's a this
is the main centerpiece of the Ontario
Science Center they took in 240
applications from around the world and
they picked the top 40 of us and gave us
each a couple of thousand dollars to
design a maquette and then they brought
the top 10 of us in and they asked us
what we wanted to present and I said and
the other nine asked for you know just a
room with a PowerPoint presentation and
I said just give me a garden hose
outside and the other nine all did their
presentation in her business suit I did
my presentation in a bathing suit
outside connected to a garden hose and
they loved it and so this is the final
piece that was installed
so you can see here we have immersive
multimedia and and this is this is an
example another example of water over
Internet Protocol this is another piece
here and we got all these things we make
our own underwater listening devices
also there's no hydrophones we've been
able to find that really perform well in
terms of localized listening to listen
at exactly the right place so we make
our own hydrophones make our own
underwater listening devices that listen
at exactly the right place to get the
best sound in terms of this is a piece
that we did for the Canadian National
Institute for the blind we made a note
to our classroom turns out that blind
people have the same sense of touch that
necessarily makes great hydraulic phone
playing so there's a natural segue here
into this outdoor classroom complete
with a little this is the nasty her
named Nessie like the Loch Ness monster
she's the hydraulic own and there's a
little replica of her in this tactile
classroom there's a whole tactile map so
that a blind person can feel where
everything is in the park including this
little Nessie here and locate it and go
over and play on and my daughter when
she was six years old really summed it
up nicely she did a little presentation
at the water festival because somebody
asked me how it worked and I said oh why
don't we let my six-year-old explain so
she came up and she explained it in
terms of how you make it because she's a
true maker so she put F equals C over
2pi times square root of a over VL and
then she brought the L over and got C
over 2pi whole squared times a over V
which is more or less how you make it
not so much how it works but close
enough and this is all about making
making things and so when I grew up
radios and everything you could see in
how they worked this is a radial
typically from the 1950s and when I was
growing up people were throwing away a
lot of these radios on the curb and you
could go by garbage morning and collect
them and I didn't have a lot of funds at
the time so I just mostly collected
things from the curbside and and rebuilt
them to repurpose them in and made them
into new things and so this is looking
in the back of the Radiohead know back
on it you could look right inside it and
there is a schematic diagram on once
here's a complete diagram that outlines
exactly how it works and on the other
side there's a parts list I thought
thank you Westinghouse for making it
easy for me to understand how this radio
works so that I can modify it and do
things with it and all these glass
valves here are all transparent and you
can look inside them and see how they
work little light bulbs you know and you
can see and television tubes were
transparent then as well and you could
see inside them and then in the 70s we
start to see this technology spying on
his microwave motion sensors and burglar
alarms and I wanted to see what it was
spying I said this thing's watching me I
want to know how it's watching me what
can it understand about me so I open it
up and take a look inside and here's
what I get
I noticed the manufacturer here the
manufacturer took the extra time to to
give us maps explaining how it worked
and here the manufacturer took the extra
time to grind the numbers off all the
chips to make it harder to understand
how it worked
so we went from nice roadmaps like this
to gouges and scratches like this so
welcome to the modern era where
everything watches you and reveals
nothing about itself and so I got
interested in video feedback like many
people and you know you can walk around
to the camera and point it at a TV
screen but I kind of did the opposite I
took the television camera and walked
around with a television receiver moving
it around to pick up the television
signal and this is what I got in a long
exposure photograph moving a television
receiver around the room tuned into that
television channel and then I realized I
didn't need to carry the whole TV set
around I could just carry a light bulb
around see here's a one and a half
kilowatt light bulb connected to my
lock-in amplifier I built perhaps the
world's most powerful lock-in amplifier
with a two and a half kilowatt output a
television receive antenna terminals and
pick up the TV signal and then make it
feed back and when the light source is
in view of the camera it would glow more
brightly and when it wasn't it would go
less brightly and here's what I got
and this is a little bunch of
photographs from a film strip that are
chained together as a gif image and so
this is kind of what happens the light
ball waves around and shows us what is
there and there is the amplifier from
1974 and I built that in a wooden case
which is probably a silly idea but as a
child I slowly learned
luckily it didn't catch on fire and
here's 35 lightbulbs on a stick waving
through space
seeing the sight field of the camera and
this is what I call phenomenological
augmented reality and so this is AR from
the seventies wearable AR this is
perhaps the world's first wearable
computer with little shoulder strap to
carry it around and I discovered this
concept what I call sitting waves here
standing waves standing waves are like a
skipping rope or a violin string gives
you with a nodes fixed and the wave goes
positive amplitude negative amplitude
and so on and then here's the wave form
from my apparatus and you can see it's
moving here it hasn't quite sat still
down boy down boy sit good boy
they're sitting that's what you call a
sitting wave and so that wave is just
sitting still and just as a comparison
point of view there's a standing wave on
the left and a standing wave as the
product is the sum of waves traveling in
opposite directions a sitting wave is
the product of waves traveling in the
same direction and here's the apparatus
and here's some sitting waves circularly
polarized radio wave visualization which
was kind of cut into as a visual art
form creating visual art of course you
got to have a low world for a wearable
computer here it is an exhibit at the
National Gallery and it still works
after 42 years this is with some LEDs
picking up the signal there's Neil
Harvison the colorblind cyborg and so
the basic principle is that what we have
is a space space rather than a time base
you can use an oscilloscope to see
waveforms but they're situated in time
and not necessarily aligned with space
and here I see a jumbled mess I'm
that microwave motion sensor which I'm
trying to unlock its secrets when I put
it to an oscilloscope it doesn't tell me
much but when I put it to the
oscilloscope and move the oscilloscope
and the way I discovered this is my dad
got me an oscilloscope that was broken
somebody was throwing away that was
about 40 years ago and it was about 40
years old about 80 years old now and the
sweep didn't work on it so I started
pushing it across the workbench to get
it to sweep in my eye using persistence
of exposure in my eye and then I
realized I discovered something very
interesting and that is what it
discovered is what I call
phenomenological augmented reality that
is to say I had perfect registration
because the registration occurs due to
physics not due to some laggy software
but the registration happens at the
speed of light and so the alignment
between the real and virtual worlds
occurs at the speed of light with exact
accuracy and so as a result every time I
swung that thing back and forth they
would follow up and down the peaks and
valleys of that wave and so here's a
long exposure photograph moving the
oscilloscope with the time axis turned
off and I see there and of course if I
use my row of lights this is a little
robot that my nine-year-old made and she
can now see the radio wave so here we
have the electric field shown in green
and the magnetic field shown in magenta
she made a little thing to flip the
thing 90 degrees and then we changed the
dipole antenna to a loop antennas we put
the magnetic field and so you can see
here that we can see radio waves so a
lot of this thing as science as art of
exhibited at Museum of Modern Art New
York static museum Smithsonian Institute
and so on visualizing radio waves with
smart fabrics so I made and my childhood
a lot of these smart clothes and smart
fabrics I made my own clothing much to
my mother's dismay writing wire through
the sewing machine and doing all kinds
of crazy things like that and this is
you know phenomenological augmented
reality of a surveillance camera those
lights are soo survey luminescent and
they light up when they're being watched
here's the open motel here in California
not far from here where we stayed and
the world around us contains so many
sensors in our building there's not a
toilet or urinal or hand wash faucet
that doesn't have a camera in it not
just a camera but a structured light
source and a complete computer vision
system usually the pixel count is fairly
small like 128 or thousand and 24 pixels
in a linear array and usually the light
sources a lock in a but the pixels a
small pixel count but they're it's
essentially a lock in camera because
each pixels locked into a certain
carrier around 40 kilohertz or so so
here's the sight field of that can't run
this as a form of visual art allows us
to see that which is unseen so there's
the old question who watches the
Watchers but I don't think anybody asked
the more important question who watches
the watching who senses the sensors and
senses their capacity to sense and a
meta conversation is a conversation
about conversations a meta joke is a
joke about jokes so I had this idea of
meta sensing meta vision meta valence
which is the seeing of sight the sensing
of sensors and sensing their capacity to
sense and the vision of visualization
and then a robotic arm swinging that
back and forth here's a microwave motion
sensor and we can see it's waves here's
a surveillance camera with a robotic arm
tracing out at site field more generally
here is a new way of interacting with
the world using ibaka grothy or a vaca
grothy and so what we have here is this
concept of the space-time continuum this
is Jay's Hansen he's the Hollywood's
number one sort of graphical user
interface designer he did Hunger Games
Ender's Game and so on and he's one of
our employees at Madden now so here's a
couple of examples there's a conduit an
information conduit coming from the hand
gesture to open an electronic door or we
can have the information conduit that
shows us how to find her way to class
how to not get lost just walk down the
pipe and so it's all about different
ways of interpreting the space-time
continuum so this goes back to a long
history from the 70s and 80s
wearable Aguila I gossip based devices
and things of that sort and the iTap
principle which you can read about in
the nitrous spectrum which says that the
rays of light if you look at the either
the camera is pointing this way and it's
the eye itself is the camera and that's
what I discovered in that in the 70s I
found this thing gave me a headache
and then I found no I need to do
something that makes it not give me a
headache and the eye itself has to be
the camera was the itec principle so
wearable computing wearable cameras so I
brought this to MIT to found the MIT
wearable computing project I use this
sort of as my portfolio for admission to
MIT and successfully started this
Negroponte he said Steve man's the
perfect example of someone deemed to be
analytic fringe but persisted his vision
end up founding a new discipline and so
one of my inventions was HDR high
dynamic range which is here the welding
element to see a dynamic range of close
to a billion to one and Raymond Loewy
here and myself and various others did
this you can see the four different
exposures done in real time cemented
together see welding image for the first
time in human history the tungsten
electrode example then of course there's
a are overlays we did augmented reality
overlays on top of that I'd mediated
reality here's the original work on the
HDR invention and 35 years of digital
eyeglass $0.06 synthetic synesthesia of
the sixth sense I used to call it
synthetic synesthesia of the sixth sense
because we add new senses and of course
we just got a reavie eight to six cents
so I just quickly conclude by sort of
wrapping through a couple of these
inventions the contact lens display from
1999 the implantable camera from 2000
there's the patent for it 50 best
inventions of 2009 Time magazine
implantable and then here is our
interacts on product that I was passing
around the brain computer interface it
started out as a rough prototype crazy
in fact
I've brought this to San Francisco and I
showed Kevin Kelly and he really loved
it and um this was back in the in the
1990s and then he talked about this is
quantified self the wristwatch
videophone 1998 published on the cover
Linux Journal 2000 and finally to
conclude I'll just conclude by saying a
couple of things
feedback delayed his feedback denied
think about humanistic intelligence not
artificial intelligence that is to say
think about sousveillance systems you
have to have sousveillance them the
machine should reveal itself it doesn't
have to foist itself upon you when you
don't want it to but it should not
conceal itself from you the user if the
user so chooses should be able to see an
understandin state if and when the user
so desires it doesn't necessarily have
to constantly be bombarding the user was
unwanted information but it has to
disclose when asked direct user
interfaces natural user interfaces ding
query tinkering is a form of inquiry our
bollocks augmented reality robotics and
integral kinesiology finally being
digital is being quantized and start
using software as a general pejorative
if we can start thinking about software
and then I got this concept of software
free computing which we can talk about
later on so we have a little bit of time
a couple of minutes for questions and
answers and then and then I want to
follow up outside with anybody because
I'm available for the afternoon and we
can have fun by the fountain playing on
the side Rolla phone or we can talk and
meet and I want to learn about what some
of you guys are doing to us some
fascinating work that I've become aware
of ki Wang here is doing some really
interesting work I want to hook up with
him and collaborate and lots of other
people I want to collaborate with who
are in this room so I want to connect
with people today and start
collaborations I'm collaborating with
Sean Fullmer we the day I came here I
just met him that day and within a week
we wrote a paper together and got it
submitted still waiting back but we did
this thing where we can feel radio waves
using touch and haptics
so shoot me some questions
so the hydraulic phones that you made
they are they generating sound
acoustically or digitally um so they're
generating sound unusually so the way
they generate sound is that there's a
bluff body with water flowing liquid
flowing across us there's a little
whistle or edge and that generates edge
tones and some of them have pipes that
reinforce those edge tones and get them
to go the mass of the water in some
conduit against the compression of the
water in some cavity or reservoir equals
in effect like an LC tank circuits its
resonant and some of them are entirely
acoustic and human powered so they don't
have any electrical components in them
at all others do to customer demand have
amplification and listening devices and
so these hydrophones are unlike
underwater microphones that listen and
then there's a little whistle in there
that a listener block we call it a
whistle was a listening port and that
listens and then that amplifies and we
often like undal processing HDR we often
have a high gain channel and a low gain
channel and we merge those together it's
all sort of did on digital processing
with digital signal processing using
swarm modulation to allow us to hear the
subsonic and ultrasonic capacity signals
so some of these go from you know 0
cycles per second all the way up into
the megahertz range and take all that
richness of the water and bring it to
your ear like a guitar effects pedal in
a sense but but undal you know giving
you the actual subsonic and ultrasonic
sounds in the water together with the
natural acoustic sounds in that in the
audio range we call that hyper acoustic
instrument
so cool right so thank you for your talk
I'm wondering so I love this idea of
community intelligence and the feedback
the latest feedback tonight and I think
you know in the diagram you showed
earlier you're thinking about this soon
balance and you know this main
limitation of a lot of software systems
today being that there is this Gulf of
evaluation of the user that we can't
understand what the computing system is
doing because it's not you know showing
us the steam and you know as we were
talking over lunch you mentioned this is
a problem too and how do you think
designers of computing system software
systems can do a better job of exposing
state when you need it and then making
it more transparent when you do the
first thing I would suggest is reading
that humanistic intelligence paper that
I wrote in 1998 humanistic intelligence
concept and to try to take that to heart
you see like Raymond at meta the example
of the meta is a really good example of
what we call anti jesters you know like
like sensing anti jesters not
gesture-based it's anti gesture-based it
sun digital and so the big thing is to
be undal and to make that state
incrementally discoverable and
differentiable and it's not so much
about watching the user I think people
have become obsessed with watching the
user with more and more intricate
cameras you know you know when you're
when you're peeing or washing your hands
they're using watching the television
there's a camera watching you and it's
got so much data on you and yet it's
revealing very little about itself you
know and I think maybe we should have
some way of making visible and not an
annoying way or a distracting way but
when I push the button on my TV it
should immediately acknowledge the fact
that it's been pressed so that I can
then wait my three seconds rather than
have to hit it again not sure if it's
been pressed so when I work with Steve I
create a wearable computer that I can
wear every day and man that depth
sensing
on the forehead right that's the
beginning of where really think is
useful the only thing I did for that
interface was to project a number called
distance to my eye nothing more nothing
less and it's continuous 60 frame per
seconds to a point of my eye I cannot
detect the difference and that is why I
think Steve is mentioned and so on you
can constantly observe and allow you to
know what is going on with the system to
me it is just a purely a number it's
much more powerful because from there I
become superhuman for like a week I can
note this since so well if we wore my
sensory so right now approximately 2.5
meters approximately
right at that time I get 2.5 for Wow I
got the extra centimeters of accuracy by
wiring my brain food a sensory that's
why the Iraq input throughput system if
you don't close a loop
think about sensor input is the depth
the output what do you see right if it's
a color is the digit as long as
continuously observable and it's to my
eye and is in every day that interface
will be much more successful than having
a cell phone of the pull-up you have a
depth sensor you have to click a button
to drag and drop every single thing
before I get number that make a huge
difference when it comes to a wearable
computing has to be direct but not life
through a set of interface of steps and
that's what it means from understanding
by doing it everyday as well right yeah
I think that's a really good explanation
like wearable computing for by its very
nature tends to bring us towards the
notion of humanistic intelligence
wearable computing is the first step
towards humanistic intelligence and I
always would say that we have smart
things we've got smart light switches
smart toilet smart elevators Smart TVs
how about smart people you know like why
not put some of this intelligence on
people in the right sort of way you know
so we get this good impedance match I
like to say that technology's a runaway
monster that needs to be tamed with a
piece of itself you'll get all this
stuff around us but it's really annoying
you know like a I find myself not happy
with most of the technology that I see
in the modern world I'm unhappy with it
because I grew up building this stuff
inventing designing building and making
these things before the
many of them existed and so I came to
the idea that they would serve me and
they would be responsive and not that I
would sit there and push something in
wait and wait and wait and I think that
there's just too much of this bad design
and I think if you read that humanistic
intelligence paper I suggest as a
starting point to read some of this work
and let's have some dialogue let's have
some more discussion about these
principles and see if you disagree with
some of the mind some of you are saying
well no the use not every user should be
bombarded with everything but I'm saying
that at least when you want to it
shouldn't be hidden from you I'd like to
think of the Greek concept of ilithyia
lethea means being hidden and in Greek
you negate something providing a in
front notes so a lethea means not hidden
and so I think it's Alethea metric
systems as what I sometimes call it you
know systems that are unhidden that if
you wish to see them you can but you
don't have to be bombarded by them micro
research is going against everything you
expect of which is hiding information
sight text out to a point where first a
person who you know who's actually
wearing a digital form of energy so
interaction just by a natural touch and
getting output also from the fabric
itself without seeing digital forms and
we then and my point is people say oh
there's a lot of things grabbing people
attention they don't need this more
information but I think in your talk you
there are two points that are not clear
so you're talking about the state of the
machine and that's important even for
the person who's not a researcher or he
doesn't know want to know more about the
machine responsive machines and the
state of them she is important but how
it works I think this is what a small
group of people would be interested in
knowing how it works and maybe this is
where an AR display or like and lay a
layer of AR would be interesting this
would this layer would only be worn by
people who are already interested
knowing more about machine so machine
from my perspective should conceal
everything except it's taken it a a main
output but how it works it should be
something that's a privilege AR where
where a person should always be well you
don't want to rob these radios and
everything they revealed everything to
me parts list schematic regardless of
whether I applied for a developer
license or something you know there is
no the concept of developer and user
that distinction is I think corrosive to
scientific pursuit you see I think there
shouldn't need to be a distinction it
should be gradual it shouldn't be
digital or binary there's a threshold in
effect where you don't get to know
something that how something works until
you apply to become a developer well I
want to take that small increment to
curiosity of just take a peek inside Oh
No okay that's fine or maybe yes I want
to go deeper it should be undid all I
think the distinction between developer
and users should be unde it'll it should
just be fluidly flowing so if I want to
know more I can peek more in fact maybe
the machine should even sense that I
want to know more about it and give me
more like if I've got that quizzical
look maybe it gives me more revealing
about its state or something you know so
it's not bombarding us underneath
necessarily with state but it it fluidly
shows us more and more state gradually
without having to take a jump abrupt
discontinuity of having to actually put
on some special device to see it
you